right now I am the table I have a
question for the ladies
um how much would you say your
submission cost
what do you mean submission
um actually my first question so would
you submit to a man meaning that you
trust his authority and his judgment so
if there's big decisions you trust him
to make decisions
and my second question is if so how much
would that cost so let's say he said
quit your job I want you to be home with
the kids how much would you have to make
for you to trust his judgment
foreign
it's a good question I mean there's not
really the price to it you know you kind
of trust the human being in general or
trust the person or you're not so
fifteen thousand pounds a year you trust
him there's no one is involved at all in
my kind of relationship in general
whatever like money comes along because
like I do [ __ ] I don't care because the
money comes and money goes so that's
always investment so and anything so 15
he makes 15 000 pounds a year
okay he's a Brokey and but that's the
thing I don't really care how much man
makes like once I can make the money
with that man together that's like where
there is the partnership no but I'm
saying like he's not changing his income
so a lot of girls will try to answer the
question because they'll say oh he can
make more in the future no no no no this
isn't build a bomb
he's a bum he's gonna be a bum so he
makes 15 000 pounds a year
um you think he's cute whatever um
you're dating him
do you trust him to make decisions
you mean our decision is a personal so
so I'll give you an example I don't give
anybody permission to make decisions for
me okay so you would never trust a man
to make decisions
until some certain point I don't know
what kind of decisions have to be made
I'm talking about life decisions so
let's say do we live in the city or the
country
um how much do you budget each month how
many kids are we gonna have okay
whatever they think it's like it's
mutual agreement but the whole point is
at some point you guys are going to
disagree at some point right like it
might not you guys might agree on 90 of
things but that 10 when you guys
disagree it's saying you know what I'm
I'm gonna trust him to make decisions
would you do that or no
well if the man's not
stable dead end so we're like no you
know I I agree no I agree I don't think
you should at 15 000 pounds he like I
think that's mad but it's not really
about the money again like he can make
15 000 he can make a hundred [ __ ]
thousand but at the same time it depends
what he's gonna do with that money even
with 15 where he's spending what he's
doing like with his lifestyle like what
what he knows like and is he progressing
is he growing oh it's if the man stays
at least
so there's like there's like I wouldn't
be with that man okay with that thing I
agree with you you shouldn't okay that's
that's not a lot of money so I'm saying
how much does he have to make for you to
be with him
what's the minute like we all know
there's a minimum but it's not about the
money I understand it's not only money
but there has to be a money component
so you're just asking how much yeah how
much yeah how much for you to trust his
judgment
the Judgment based on the money it's
like no the Judgment should be based on
the values on the truth
that doesn't pay bills man I can
understand what she's coming from based
off your your original question how much
does your submission cost you when it
comes to
um when it comes to a man and him being
in his masculinity you should want to be
able to submit regardless so I can
understand where she's coming from
um
to answer your question for
um uh it would be more than 15. but
I don't know
what's the what's the average in the UK
I think it's like 38 38 000 I think okay
so what I had in my head I would say 50
minimum 50 okay 50. yeah okay is this
like a year or a month yeah
a year what are you gonna make it 50
kids
I mean if that's it
the average salary is 38 000 pounds when
you say 50 do you mean dollars or pounds
just pounds okay pounds which would be
what like 40
[Music]
we got one person who hasn't answered
the question yet okay
um it's quite a hard question it's like
do I wanna like let him
foreign
I like to do all of that stuff myself
you know and I'm I want a future for
myself like I'm trying to create a
future for myself
um so I don't know if I it's it's a
really hard question do you are you do
you hold on to your Independence is that
what you're saying like it's not that
I'm like oh I don't want anyone in my
life or I don't you know if it happens
it happens you know but right now in my
life that that I wouldn't have any like
specific time for like a relationship
that would work probably you know like
but um
I don't know it's hard I would I would
kind of want to find a balance between
both of us um but to answer your
question it would
obviously be like around the same amount
the money yeah about 50. yeah but but
that is so hard like personally I
probably wouldn't do it if you're if
your man became if you were with your
man and he was you know making good
money and you're married to him me too
had like a good great laugh together and
he
fell on hard times and then became quite
broke for a while would you do you think
you'd end up leaving him no no I would I
would either be the one taking your job
maybe trying to support us you know in
the end is is not about like
um leaving based on money you know is it
can be for some people but for me now I
would I wouldn't do that I said I said
because you know like when it comes to
divorce one of the major reasons is
because of finances yeah
your mom
and and then her like taking care of two
children and I saw her working hard for
us so for me it's like no I would I
would take over or find trying to help
or you know what I mean
it's stupid to well I won't say that I
think it's
insensitive and ignorant to leave
somebody from a woman's perspective if a
man is taking care of you providing for
you and then he falls on a hard time and
all of a sudden you're just like you
know what
you can't you're not making any money
you're a bum blah blah I'm Gonna Leave
You it's just like whoa he had every
chance in the world to leave you because
he's provided for you essentially you're
the bum so I feel like there's some
women that don't think of it from that
perspective like
your your man has falled on Hard Times
whatever the situation is you should
want to be like okay now I can't I can
help him out in every way possible
because typically men are like no I want
to support you now it's like okay oh I
get the chance to support my man however
long it may be do you guys think
relationships can work where the woman
makes more than the man for an extended
period of time no
no
yeah I think so if the woman doesn't
come at it at a conniving and like uh
very like oh I'm I'm making the money
now you see but that's exactly how it's
going to be whether it's in your face or
sound no matter what it's always going
to be there when it took too long to
come down in the night out you used to
do the last toilet but it's just gonna
be the same thing over I have a question
for you Jess yeah so all right let's say
let's say your YouTube channel just goes
crazy subscribe subscribe to her Channel
subscribe now you're bringing home 100K
a year now so you you marry a guy that
makes 50k um or 60 in the US
my question is
he wants to buy you want you have a
certain house that you want he has a
certain house that he wants are you
willing even though you bringing in more
money for the house to let him pick
am I willing to give up that house yeah
so you want let's say you want a four
bedroom house he wants a two-bedroom
house are you willing to give up your
dream house and let him pick even though
you're bringing in more money what I
would do is I would see how we can meet
in the middle no that's not that's not
submission
that's not submission it's not mean in
the middle it's like his way
even though you're bringing in more
money
I think we we already know
it's a because I it may not be like oh
yes automatically but it'd be like okay
is this beneficial like if if he thinks
it's beneficial like that house is
beneficial for us in the future we
wouldn't have to up and move tell them
okay yeah sure but I would want to
understand like where he was coming from
and why he would want that house instead
of the other one I have to say like oh
mine's the best we should get it but if
he says like financially right now we
should down to grade or go this way I'd
be like okay I see it I see where you're
coming so who's this final decision it
would be
it would be his final decision I because
I I'm the type of person I want to
understand where the person's coming
from and just saying like do you think
that's common no as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible